cache D has just dethroned the king
visionande as India's number one player
the 17 year old gukesh also entered the
top 10 in the world going undefeated in
the Turkish super league and winning his
first two games of the World Cup vichy's
reign as India's number one has been
held since 1986 with only one brief
moment in 2016 when pentala Hare Krishna
claimed the spot with the margin of 0.3
rating points in a matter of days Vichy
reclaimed his spot and has held on until
now kukesh's rapid Ascent has
transformed him from an up-and-coming
Prodigy to a rival with the world's best
in a country with a vibrant chess
culture and many prodigies such as
pragdananda and nihal sarin it's even
more impressive than